for reaction from San Diego let's bring
in Robert hire he's a cousin of Brian
Terry who was another border agent
killed and the chairman of the Brian
Terry foundation and of course remember
mr. Terry was that Border Patrol agent
killed in the line of duty back in 2010
in the infamous Fast & Furious scandal
Robert and the foundation have been
assisting the family of the slain border
agent during this tough time and we're
delighted he's with us this is just
another sickening example of the
violence at the border and people think
it's just at the border itself but as we
know these cartels and and other thugs
and criminals are operating within 18
miles inside the United States with
assault weapons in this case presumably
they they pelted the victim with rocks
and other things your reaction
that's right Laura you know it's it's a
violent violent environment very kinetic
just as we saw with Brian Terry those
armed rip crews were professional
criminals that came and went back across
the border time and time again to do one
thing and that was greed violence on the
American side of the border in this case
we believe that Border Patrol agent
Rogelio Martinez was ambushed by
individuals
he was then violently beaten and thank
God his partner survived who was also
gravely badly injured but it's a very
very violent environment on the border
and I think Americans have had enough
they elected a president to secure the
border and look where we exist to do one
thing and that is to speak out on issues
that affect the safety and well-being of
Border Patrol agents this was the 39th
Border Patrol agent killed in the line
of duty since 2003
enough is enough we have to secure the
borders I want to know exactly what
these animals did to agent Martinez I
don't want it whitewashed I want to know
exactly what they did to him and I want
it I want to know who these people are
they better be apprehended and if if
they're coming across the Mexican border
maybe there's maybe there's Central
Americans we don't know but all I know
is President Trump was ridiculed and
laughed at when he was said build the
wall this they're pouring into this
country with criminals and thugs and
drugs and guns and all sorts of human
trafficking going on it's dangerous for
the migrants who are crossing the border
who do want a better life and our heart
goes out to them it's dangerous for them
and unfortunately for American citizens
it's dangerous for us it's not just the
people of Texas or the Border Patrol
Border Patrol's on the front line but
these people end up in Northern Virginia
they end up in Minneapolis they end up
in Boston Hartford LA Oakland and
everywhere in between this is what a
failed government system does to the
people of its own country this is
another wake-up call and I note
president Trump watches this show and
this better be the final straw for these
members of Congress build this wall get
this done well I think you're exactly
right
look Americans are gravely concerned I
think the wake-up call was when Brian
Terry was killed is almost seven years
ago next month well apparently not
apparently not if it was a wake-up call
we would have Congress not going home
for you know long recesses would have
Congress who are actually in town saying
we're gonna allocate real money to this
border we're gonna hire more agents
we're not gonna have drones flying over
and reporting back to headquarters we're
gonna people on the ground they're gonna
be turned right back at the border and
if you protest the Border Patrol agents
we're gonna arrest you too because
you're probably violating the law
because you're interfering with the
actions of a law enforcement officer I'm
sorry this is his family deserves
justice here just like you helped Brian
Terry's family get their own justice and
and
you can close it out I'm just so
infuriated at this this is this should
never be happening in the United States
of America
well I and I think the American public
spoke out when they elected president
Trump as president now Congress maybe
they still need to wake up I can tell
you though that when elected officials
either on the local county state or
federal level speak out in fanned the
flames of protesters looking to protest
against people and yeah that is
completely unacceptable we are we are
Americans together through bad and good
times good times now Robert you're being
too charitable the people who are who
are protesting these agents from
carrying out their duty are part of the
problem they are acting criminally and
what they're doing and that's all they
are is their criminal protesters they
themselves are acting in a criminal
fashion so all the all the platitudes
about where all unite no we're not all
united some people want the laws
violated other people want the rule of
law that's it that's that's what's going
right I really appreciate your joining
us thank you so much for what you're
doing for these border predict you
families we need more people like you